recently I lost a very good friend of
mine Sam Shepard and of course every Sam
Shepard a beautiful writer and I thought
it would be nice to sing a little song
for him
Oh to be not anyone gone this major
being skin
[Music]
Oh to cry II not any cry so Mun 'full
that the Dove Geist laughs and the
steadfast gasps
Oh - OH
not anyone nothing to be
not here but here
forsaken all equatorial bliss who walked
through the callow
mist dress T in scraps the walked the
curve of the world
whose bones scraped whose flesh on fur
world who grieves not anyone gone to
greet blame the inspired stars amazed to
stumble where gods get lost beneath
[Music]
this Southern Cross
amazed to stumble where gasps get lost
beneath the Southern Cross
[Music]
you